[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sont plus tarder voici le
sommaire focus dans ce magazine sur les
pôles de compétitivité quels sont leurs
objectifs de quelle manière 50 ans neeve
et est impliqué dans ses moteurs de
croissance
nous répondrons à ces questions avec
nous en plateau le chrono est directeur
stratégie et développement défense et
sécurité chez berthe en technologie
cette entreprise implantée à montigny le
bretonneux est engagé dans plusieurs
pôles les derniers chiffres de la
croissance française sont bons + 1,9
pour cent en 2017 selon l'insee c'est le
plus haut niveau enregistré depuis six
ans nous verrons si cette reprise
économique est notable dans les yvelines
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique dans les
yvelines avec notamment la promesse du
département de baisser les impôts et le
top des métiers qui recrutent en 2018
dans notre département
mais avant de développer tous ces
chiffres commençons avec un chiffre 12
le 29 mars prochain les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines auront douze
heures pour recruter leurs futurs
collaborateurs
le vélodrome nationale accueillera la
première édition en piste pour l'emploi
le site internet à sky emploi permet aux
entreprises souhaitant trouver leurs
talents de demain de s'inscrire dès à
présent vous avez d'ailleurs jusqu'au 15
février 1900 emplois seront à pourvoir
on poursuit avec un autre chiffre celui
de la croissance du pib selon l'insee en
2017 la croissance a atteint 1,9 pour
cent en france c'est le plus haut niveau
enregistré depuis six ans
la tendance était la même dans les
yvelines c'est ce qu'ont voulu savoir
nicolas landry et mika l'année et demi
d'euros une croissance moyenne de 100 %
entre 2016 et 2017 c'est le résultat du
dirigeant saint quentinois yves ten
spécialiste en prise de participations
dans les sociétés il est à la tête d'un
groupe de six entreprises spécialisées
dans la restauration et la communication
oui je fonds depuis quelques temps
un début de reprise principalement liée
à une accélération des prises de
décision par nos donneurs d'ordre est
donc cette accélération de décision est
propice à avoir filmé en plus de projets
autre entreprise à coignières cet
atelier propose de créer une stratégie
de publicité création de supports
d'affichage ou de logos alexandre david
réalise avec ses cinq collaborateurs
près de 500000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires
la relance économique est perçu à
travers ses carnets de commandes en
douceur 2018 on vise à une augmentation
du chiffre d'affaires de 30%
ça va se traduire par notamment
infections alan ball d'un commercial
l'acquisition de nouveaux secteurs
d'activité on a investi derrière envoyer
de nouvelles machines dans lequel on
n'investit pour créer plus rapidement à
livrer plus rapidement nos clients donc
on compte aussi sur ça pour aller
chercher un levier de croissance
du côté de soap emea spécialisée dans
les essais industriels dans
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire ou encore
le nucléaire
l'année 2010 est a été stable en terme
de résultats mais les signes de reprise
ne sont pas évidents ce qui est
important pour nous c'est les nouveaux
avions et nouveau type d'avion qui vont
sortir ou les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires ou les nouvelles technologies
ça c'est notre métier est aujourd'hui
effectivement il n'y a pas de nouveauté
dans ces mythes danser monde dans lequel
nous évoluons nous investissions à
l'étranger ou non racheter un
laboratoire en angleterre on s'interroge
sur d'autres pays européens voir sur
d'autres pays en dehors de l'europe pour
pouvoir effectivement les chercher des
relais de croissance que nous trouvons
pas suffisamment en france croissance
investissement et emplois la reprise
varie en fonction du secteur d'activité
les chefs d'entreprise sont unanimes sur
le besoin de visibilité sur le long
terme
ouvrons à présent notre dossier
thématique consacré au pôle de
compétitivité créé il ya une dizaine
d'années il rassemble sur un territoire
des entreprises ont encore des
laboratoires de recherche
saint quentin en yvelines est impliqué
dans plusieurs pôles comme nous allons
le voir à travers ce reportage
avec son université ses centres de
recherche publics et privés et ses
entreprises innovantes
saint quentin en yvelines est impliqué
dans plusieurs pôles de compétitivité
mais au fait un pôle de compétitivité
c'est quoi exactement
la vocation d'un pôle de compétitivité
c'est de rassembler dans un territoire
donné donc ile-de-france pour
systématique des acteurs des entreprises
des académiques autour d'une thématique
donnée celle de systématique c'est celle
en fait des enjeux de l'infrastructure
du numérique et du logiciel dans toutes
ses dimensions
implanté sur le plateau de saclay
systematic paris région est organisée
selon si technologiques les big data et
intelligence artificielle confiance
numérique et cybersécurité
infrastructures numériques logiciels
libres modélisation et simulation
numérique et systèmes embarqués pour les
entreprises faire partie d'un pôle de
compétitivité est souvent synonyme de
croissance mais pas qu aujourd'hui on
est dans une accélération de
l'innovation et il faut aller est scooté
chercher cette innovation à l'extérieur
des murs de l'entreprise et c'est ce que
fait en fait systématiquement en ouvrant
les murs entre les petites et les
grandes entreprises en ouvrant les murs
entre les acteurs du public les acteurs
du privé pour accélérer cette démarche
innovante
parmi les 800 membres de systematic
paris-region à l'estaca au total l'école
d'ingénieurs installé à montigny le
bretonneux est impliqué dans cinq pôles
de compétitivité
ça tape
question c'est un travers la
participation dont des projets
collaboratifs labellisés par les pôles
de compétitivité
actuellement l'estaca est engagé dans le
projet module d'intégration et de
simulation mécatronique porté par le
pôle de compétitivité movéo objectif
concevoir un logiciel pour optimiser les
processus de conception de nouvelles
innovations moteur pour l'estac à il
existe de nombreux intérêts à faire
partie d'un pôle de compétitivité un
intérêt pour conduire une recherche
appliquée on lit à direct avec les
problèmes industriels allaient monter la
formation
développer la formation doctorale et un
dernier point très important pour nous
c'est permettre de mettre en place des
collaborations structurantes inscrite
dans la durée
au total sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines une cinquantaine
d'acteurs sont membres de ces pôles qui
ont pour vocation de soutenir
l'innovation ou encore de favoriser le
développement de projets collaboratifs
de recherche et de développement et nous
a rejoint en plateau luc grenouille
bonsoir bonjour vous êtes directeur
stratégie et développement défense et
sécurité chez bertin technologies alors
votre entreprise est basée à montigny le
bretonneux
elle fait partie en de plusieurs pôles
de compétitivité dont systématique
langue que l'on a pu voir dans ce
reportage
pour commencer quelques mots sur les
activités de bertin technologies les
activités de bertin technologie qui fait
partie du groupe familial que nîmes qui
ne grosse ce pays de plus de 500
millions d'euros de chiffres d'affaires
présentent très fortement à
l'international
bertin technologies travaille dans le
secteur de la défense des des
technologies et de l'énergie en
fournissant essentiellement des
équipements mais aussi des services à
nos clients et la société réalise un
chiffre d'affaires qui avoisine les 100
millions d'euros aujourd'hui avec une
croissance qui est régulière sur les
dernières années et un profil qui est de
plus en plus aux industriels à la fois
montigny et puis dans d'autres
territoires
alors de quelle manière est de vous
impliquer dans les pôles de
compétitivité vous êtes impliqué dans
plusieurs pôles on est impliqué dans
plusieurs pôles bon je dirais s'agissant
de systématique
on y impliquer de façon historique
puisque personnellement j'ai participé
au lancement de systématique et puis
même avant j'étais déjà présent sur le
plateau de saclay et donc je joue le jeu
j'ai tout de suite et on a tout de suite
cru à 7 à cette initiative
on est aussi assez fortement présents en
région paca donc on est présent dans des
pôles de région paca autour de nos
métiers qui sont pour l'essentiel
l'instrumentation donc souvent de
l'optique de l'électronique du logiciel
de la mécatronique donc les épaules
afférents à ces domaines nous nous
intéresse pour autant
qu'on ait une présence dans ces dans ces
territoires en quoi c'est important pour
une entreprise et puis évidemment pour
votre entreprise d'être impliqué comme
ça dans ces pôles les pôles de
compétitivité c'est un des volets de la
recherche et développement et de
l'innovation de nos de nos entreprises
donc c'est très important au titre voilà
de notre capacité à développer des
nouveaux produits et des nouveaux
services dans un monde
voilà qui est compétitif donc c'est
important de participer aux pôles de
compétitivité car on y trouve des
partenaires qu'ils soient industriels ou
laboratoires comme le disait jean luc
beylat le président effectivement on
peut aussi faire de la veille et trouver
des partenaires potentiels
après c'est pas la forme unique de deux
collaborations en termes de r&d
ce n'est pas nécessairement le propos
ici mais effectivement le paul c'est
déjà un écosystème en choix vous parlez
de croissance de votre entreprise tout à
l'heure justement le fait d'être
impliqués dans ces pôles en fait ça
booste la croissance d'une entreprise
alors dans notre cas c'est particulier
je crois que ça bouge que la croissance
des entreprises en général pour les
start up c'est extrêmement important
nous nous sommes une entreprise de
taille intermédiaire donc notre
croissance
elle forcément et s'appuie sur notre
innovation elle s'appuie beaucoup sur
notre capacité à nous projeter sur de
nouveaux marchés à l'export le marché
français marchés européens sont pas
toujours suffisants pour cela le paul
prend des initiatives pour aider encore
plus les entreprises et je crois que
c'est la bonne direction
donc notre croissance vient du pôle
entre autres une dernière question nous
donner un exemple concret de projet
justement avec un pôle de compétitivité
en ce moment avec bertin technologies
alors écoutez un des exemples concrets
j'en ai j'en ai plusieurs des projets
qui sont en cours dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité avec d'aider des projets
de deux plateformes de confiance au sein
du de la thématique confiance et
sécurité du pôle qui nous a conduits à
développer des partenariats
moi je retiens aussi un projet qu'on
avait monté il ya quelques années dans
le domaine de la détection nrbc qui nous
a conduit à rencontrer sa fille mot
société qu'on a qu'on a acheté il ya
trois ans donc vous voyez la croissance
ou du moins les aspects industriels sont
multiformes dans l'épaule et on a on a
trouvé voilà un partenaire qui est
devenue une société de du groupe
merci les prenons en tout cas d'être
intervenu à s'asseoir sur nouakchott
château quels sont les métiers qui
recrutent en 2018 dans les yvelines la
promesse du département de voir nos
impôts baisser en 2021 ou encore
l'esprit gagnon du président de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est tout de suite
dans les po en bref le président de
saint quentin en yvelines jean michel
fourgous a choisi le dernier jour du
mois de janvier pour présenter ses voeux
sa volonté pour 2018
un esprit gagnant dans les meilleurs
ingénieurs les meilleurs brevets les
meilleures entreprises
on a une université qui va certainement
prendre la première place française
[Musique]
on à paris saclay qui est un des plus
beaux rassemblements de cerveaux
français bon pour demain sortie à les
brevets faire aussi
la richesse de la france il ya quelques
jours les élus du conseil départemental
des yvelines ont validé le budget 2010 8
le budget primitif s'élève à 1,4
milliard d'euros une enveloppe de près
de 400 millions d'euros est consacré à
la réalisation de projets
d'investissement le département s'est
fixé également un objectif baisser les
impôts locaux d'ici 2021
si vous êtes à la recherche d'un emploi
direction le site internet de l'île de
france une carte interactive de notre
région proposent les métiers qui vont
recruter en 2018 dans le bassin
versailles saclay misé cette année sur
le management et l'ingéniérie le
nettoyage de locaux ou encore les études
et développements informatiques dans le
sud-ouest francilien
les métiers liés aux relations technico
commerciale comptabilité et soins
d'hygiène auront le vent en poupe en
avant de se quitter quelques rendez vous
à noter dans vos agendas mercredi 14
février le ski-club de guyancourt
organise un petit déjeuner sur la loi de
finances 2010 8c de 8h30 à 10h c'est
gratuit mais il faut s'inscrire sur le
site www.skype.com jeudi 15 février si
vous avez un projet de création
d'entreprise la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines organise un
atelier intitulé 3 2 1 créer c'est
gratuit mais là aussi il faut s'inscrire
sur le site de la cci
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 20
février pour un nouveau 7 8 et co
consacrée cette fois ci aux nouvelles
formes d'organisation du travail
à très bientôt
[Musique]